son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna Les agradecemos su
sintonía vamos con los titulares de esta
jornada
Estados Unidos se comprometió a
Modificar el acuerdo del Tercer país
seguro y Canadá aceptó recibir a 15.000
migrantes del continente el próximo año
Esos fueron algunos de los pactos a los
que llegaron el Primer Ministro Justin
trudea y el presidente Joe biden en su
encuentro en el que Washington no
descartó enviar una misión militar a
Haití
este viernes miles de argentinos
marcharon en Buenos Aires para recordar
a las víctimas de la dictadura militar
que llegó al poder hace 47 años los
manifestantes se congregaron en la Plaza
de Mayo portando pancartas con fotos de
los desaparecidos y exigiendo justicia
la atención causada por las recientes
manifestaciones contra la reforma las
pensiones en Francia forzó a aplazar la
visita del Rey Carlos III que iba a
llegar el domingo a territorio galo las
autoridades británicas informaron que
fue el presidente Manuel quien propuso
el aplazamiento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
iniciamos en Canadá donde se llevó a
cabo el encuentro oficial entre el
Primer Ministro Justin trude y el
presidente Joe biden la reunión giró en
torno a temas como la migración la
situación de Haití luce semiconductores
y la unidad como bandera para enfrentar
a regímenes autoritarios Alba Santana
tienen los detalles
es la primera visita oficial del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
al país vecino y Aliado Canadá donde el
Primer Ministro Justin trudó lo recibió
con los brazos abiertos es un verdadero
placer dar la bienvenida el presidente
biden autagua de vuelta a otawa me
alegro mucho de verte yo el principal
objetivo de la visita reforzar su
cooperación económica y social durante
la reunión anunciaron un acuerdo sobre
la migración ilegal en la frontera
compartida un tema sensible para ambos
bandos según este Canadá podrá devolver
a los migrantes en caliente sin
permitirles la entrada al país a cambio
de conceder quince mil solicitudes de
asilo un movimiento criticado por las
organizaciones humanitarias Estados
Unidos y Canadá trabajarán juntos para
desalentar los cruces ilegales en las
fronteras y aplicar el acuerdo del
Tercer país plenamente y totalmente
actualizado también discutieron otros
temas como un plan conjunto de defensa
para poder plantar cara a otras
potencias como Rusia o china
lo que hace que este sea un momento tan
trascendental es que nuestro mundo
nuestro modo de vida se enfrenta a
múltiples amenazas al mismo tiempo
e hicieron hincapié en su apoyo a
Ucrania en la región aseguraron que
siguen preocupados por la situación de
seguridad en Haití Canadá suele ser la
primera visita al extranjero del
presidente estadounidense Y aunque con
biden no fue así han querido subrayar
que la unidad norteamericana sigue
intacta
una aparente caso de intimidación se
vivió en la oficina del fiscal que
podría presentar cargos contra el
expresidente Donald Trump por supuesto
sobornos pagados a la actriz
pornográfica stormy Daniels de otra
parte el ex mandatario advirtió que de
ser procesado por este delito habrá
muerte y destrucción una afirmación que
hizo en redes sociales y que generó
fuerte polémica humanizada nos da más
detalles en el informe
no hay respiro cuando se trata de Donald
Trump este viernes el departamento de
policía de Nueva York acudió a la
oficina del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan Alvin Brock para retirar
sobres con polvo blanco de naturaleza
desconocida estos sobres fueron enviados
junto a una nota de amenaza al fiscal
que estudia presentar cargos por
supuesto sobornos de Trump a la actriz
de cine para adultos
al mismo tiempo Trump ha hecho una
incendiaria publicación en su red social
advirtiendo que habrá y destrucción si
se presenta una acusación en su contra
habrá consecuencias catastróficas según
el expresidente que tilda de psicópata
degenerado a quien se atreva a imputarlo
un tono que vuelve a causar preocupación
La retórica del expresidente que fue
sometido dos veces a juicio político es
temeraria cuestionable e irresponsable
Es peligrosa Y si sigue así va a ser que
maten a alguien ya hemos visto las
consecuencias de las incitaciones del
expresidente
el fiscal Federal devenido en abogado de
Trump Evan corcoren compareció este
viernes ante un gran Jurado Que
Investiga otro de los casos que
involucran al político republicano se
trata de la retención de documentos
clasificados después de dejar la Casa
Blanca además de acuerdo con la cadena
ABC un juez llamará a declarar al ex
jefe de gabinete de Trump Marc middles y
otros antiguos aliados por el tercer
caso que tiene abierto el asalto al
Capitolio muchos frentes de batalla para
quien planea luchar por el premio mayor
el retorno a la Casa Blanca
en Nueva York finalizó la conferencia de
la ONU sobre el agua se presentaron poco
más de 700 compromisos voluntarios
relacionados con los recursos
hídricos y el saneamiento previamente
conversamos con María Clara calle
enviada especial de France 24 que nos
contó Cuáles fueron los principales
resultados del encuentro
lo primero de recapitular que aquí se
esperaba hacer una evaluación de cómo va
la mitad del decenio de la acción por el
agua y también el objetivo de desarrollo
número 6 que tiene que ver con agua y
saneamiento no se conoció sí se
recopilaron todos los insumos y el
informe final se presentará en el foro
anual de desarrollo sostenible que Será
en julio próximo aquí mismo en Nueva
York lo que sí ocurrió fue primero el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez Se comprometió a
estudiar el reiterado llamado por crear
la figura de un enviado especial para el
agua dentro de la ONU lo segundo es que
como usted lo mencionaba hay 708
acuerdos por un valor de 300.000
millones de dólares según la ONU y de
aquellos 153 Fueron presentados por
gobiernos y lo tercero y más importante
es que el agua quedó en el centro del
debate como lo dijo el propio Gutiérrez
el agua debe ser de ahora en adelante el
eje central tanto de lo que ocurre en la
ONU como de lo que ocurra en las
discusiones políticas y muy brevemente
esta agenda de acción por el agua que es
la que recopila los compromisos se
revisará primero en el Foro de Julio
luego en la Cumbre del futuro en 2024 Y
por último en la Cumbre social del mundo
en 2025
unas 90.000 personas marcharon en
Argentina para conmemorar el día de la
memoria verdad y Justicia cuando se
cumplieron 47 años del golpe de estado
que dio origen a la última dictadura del
país los manifestantes se congregaron en
la Plaza de Mayo con pancartas y fotos
de los miles de desaparecidos para
exigir justicia por las víctimas se
estima que unas 30.000 personas fueron
desaparecidas durante la dictadura del
76 al 83
José Acosta Mi hermano en tucumán había
salido a trabajar en lo cañaverales y en
ese momento no vino fue un día 24 de
marzo que él estuvo marzo del 74 y para
nosotros hoy estar acá reflejando estos
40 años de democracia y este 24
es algo que nos lleva a continuar y
decir nunca más a lo que pasó porque
nosotros como familia la hemos pasado
hace pocas semanas la ciudad de
Argentina de Rosario fue noticia por un
tiroteo contra uno de los supermercados
de la familia de Antonia la roccuzzo la
influencer y modelo esposa de Lionel
Messi pero más allá de lo sucedido la
urbe vive un aumento de la violencia
relacionado con la presencia de grupos
de narcotraficantes en la zona una
problemática que parece salirse de las
manos del gobierno argentino el informe
es de Manuela Cano
en el barrio los pumitas se respira con
temor calle solitarias fachadas con
impactos de bala son secuelas de lo que
ha conllevado el enfrentamiento entre
pandillas narcotraficantes Joaquín en el
norte de la ciudad de Argentina de
Rosario donde Maximiliano un niño de 11
años Fue asesinado por una bala perdida
durante un tiroteo entre dos bandas del
lugar
sus residentes han presenciado el
aumento del tráfico de estupefacientes
en pequeña escala así como el de la
violencia ante la falta de presencia
Estatal los vecinos han decidido tomar
sus propias medidas demoliendo la casa
de un presunto traficante unas acciones
por las que recibieron amenazas
consistían en llamadas telefónicas y
también
personales personalmente de que el club
iba a estar sembrado de muerto y bueno
pero también Nosotros tomamos la
decisión de seguir
porque nosotros estamos convencidos que
hasta la otra parte sabe que lo que
nosotros hacemos Es correcto la
desolación de los pumitas contrasta con
otros sectores de la ciudad con un
enorme Puerto Rosario es la puerta de la
agroexportación vital para el país pero
también se ha vuelto un punto de salida
de drogas hacia Europa y Asia el mercado
de mercancías ilegales que manejan
narcotráfico
ha permitido digamos un desarrollo
exponencial del mercado inmobiliario
también por ejemplo de los bienes
sutuarios o suntuosos que se venden aquí
como autos de alta gama el narcotráfico
y sus consecuencias Siguen sin poder ser
contrarrestados por el gobierno
Rosario es la ciudad más peligrosa de
Argentina con 22 asesinatos por cada
100.000 habitantes y con casi un
homicidio por día
la misión de observación de derechos
humanos de la ONU para Ucrania dio a
conocer un informe en el que documenta
los efectos de la guerra en la población
ucraniana el organismo aseguró que las
cifras son alarmantes en términos de
ejecuciones sumarias cometidas por ambos
bandos involucrados en el conflicto
además reportó múltiples casos de
desapariciones forzadas torturas y
violencia sexual
la situación humanitaria Es crítica en
Ucrania la oficina de monitoreo de
derechos humanos de Naciones Unidas para
el país europeo desveló en un informe
parte de los efectos en la población por
la invasión rusa los civiles asesinados
se cuentan por miles
la guerra ha producido un costo humano
horrendo hasta esta semana hemos
documentado más de 8.000 civiles que han
muerto y casi 14.000 que han resultado
heridos
más del 90% fueron causados por misiles
armas o Minas explosivas y restos
explosivos de guerra
desde el 24 de febrero del año pasado la
organización ha documentado 621 casos de
desapariciones forzadas y detenciones
arbitrarias de civiles por parte de las
fuerzas armadas rusas y también reportó
133 casos de violencia sexual
relacionados con el conflicto otras de
las modalidades que preocupan a la ONU
son los traslados irregulares que
incluyen niños no acompaña desde
diversas regiones ucranianas mientras
estaban bajo control ruso
También estamos profundamente
preocupados por la ejecución sumaria de
15 prisioneros de guerra ucranianos Poco
después de ser capturados por las
fuerzas armadas rusas los contratistas
militares y de seguridad del grupo
Wagner perpetraron 11 de estas
ejecuciones
pero aseguró que Ucrania tampoco ha
estado exenta de esas prácticas y ha
documentado la ejecución sumaria de 25
prisioneros de guerra rusos
la ONU también delató casos de tortura
por parte de las fuerzas rusas más del
84% de los soldados detenidos
entrevistados por la misión sufrió tales
malos tratos el Rey Carlos III suspendió
su viaje de estado a Francia debido a la
ola de protestas y manifestaciones por
la adopción de la Reforma al sistema de
pensiones el presidente
tuvo que admitir que el clima actual de
la nación no es adecuado para una visita
real Gabriel colchón nos cuenta más
un viaje real cancelado por el clima de
tensión en Francia el presidente
Emmanuel macún confirmó que la visita
del Rey Carlos III será aplazada debido
al aula de manifestaciones que entró en
su noveno día el jueves y que dio lugar
a hechos de violencia en varias ciudades
del país
los sindicatos anunciaron una nueva
jornada de movilización el martes y la
visita del Rey estaba prevista del lunes
al miércoles creo que no estaríamos
serios y careceríamos de sentido común
si propusiéramos a Su Majestad el rey y
a la reina consorte que vinieran a
visitarnos en medio de las
manifestaciones
el rey tenía previsto viajar a Francia
el domingo por tres días en una
importante visita de estado pero el país
se ha visto afectado por las huelgas y
protestas masivas tras la adopción del
proyecto de ley que breve subir la edad
legal de jubilación de 62 a 64 años
hace bien no venir ahora hay protestas y
huelgas por todas partes si es normal ya
que París es una ciudad con verdaderos
residentes sí es una ciudad turística
pero no es solo eso hay gente que vive
aquí y que tienen necesidades
más de un millón de personas
participaron en las protestas del jueves
según el gobierno y tres coma cinco
millones según los sindicatos los
manifestantes y las organizaciones
sociales culpan al gobierno por no
prestar atención a la creciente
indignación ciudadana también lo acusan
de haber adoptado la reforma gracias al
uso de poderes especiales que forzaron
la aprobación del proyecto sin el voto
de la asamblea nacional así llegamos al
final de esta emisión de directo América
aquí en France 24 a ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega
Natalia Cabrera con toda la información
del continente americano en aquí América
feliz noche para todos
[Música]